One of the most important
processes in development is
for a cell to divide and
increase in number to generate
an entire organism.
But at some point these cells
must stop dividing and stop
proliferating and take on some
kind of specialised function,
and this might be to become a
neuron, a nerve cell, or a
muscle cell.
And this choice between
proliferation, so increasing
in number, and differentiation,
becoming
specialised, lies at
the very heart of
developmental biology.
So when geneticists are
interested in a process, they
look for situations when
it has gone wrong.
We can then work out why things
have gone wrong, and
ultimately understand
more about how the
process normally works.
What we do is we use a tiny
worm called caenorhabditis
elegans, and look for mutants,
those are worms where there
are mistakes in their DNA,
where the control of cell
proliferation and
differentiation has gone wrong.
So I'm going to show you
some really cool worms.
These worms are wild
type worms.
They're normal worms, and
they're quite happy wiggly
around on the plate.
Now, I'm not particularly
interested in the whole worm.
I'm interested in a specific
cell type called seam cells,
and these are a bit
like stem cells.
Now, these normal worms
have 16 seam cells.
We can see these cells because
we tagged the gene with a
green fluorescent protein.
Now, I'm going to show you a
type of mutant which is quite
interesting.
These worms have fewer
than 16 seam cells.
And that is because there's been
a mutation, so the DNA
sequence is not correct,
in a gene called RNT-1.
And RNT-1 is the worm version
of a human gene called RUNX.
RUNX genes, one of which is
found on chromosome 6, are
involved in cancers, and they're
key in the decision
making process between
proliferation, so making more
cells, and differentiation,
so becoming a
specialised cell type.
I'm now going to show you a
mutant which has too much
RNT-1 gene product.
So this worm has over
expression of RNT-1.
So these worms have too many
seam cells, and this is
because too much RNT-1 protein
is being made.
So essentially, I've given these
worms a tumor, which
isn't very nice.
And why these two different
types of mutants are
interesting to us is because
it shows that RNT-1, and
therefore RUNX, is very
important in the decision to
proliferate, or differentiate
and become specialised.
So what we have here is a simple
biological system in
which to study RUNX genes.
And it's hoped that the insights
gained from this tiny
but really significant worm
will help us in the fight
against cancer.